Every president attempts to frame his
first national security strategy as a
break from his predecessors. President
Trump is no different.
But what's striking is how traditional
the goals of the new strategy are:
protect the homeland; promote American
prosperity; preserve peace through
military strength; and advance American
influence through diplomacy, alliances,
help for fragile states, and by
advocating for American values. Add in
the strategy's larger goal of ensuring
a favorable balance of power in Asia,
Europe, and the Middle East – a goal that
has been the cornerstone of American
grand strategy for decades – and it's hard
to say that this strategy's broader
sweep is especially new. Ironically, if
there is a break from the past, it's with
candidate Trump's statements on foreign
policy, statements that were often more
isolationist, more protectionist, and
typically harsher towards allies than
adversaries like Russia. For those of us
who think that the traditional strategy
has served the U.S. well, this is all to the good.
Do you think President Trump will commit to his new strategy, or will he revert to policies he outlined in his
campaign? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.